اعلن النظام السوري اصابه خمسه عسكريين
جراء ما سماه عدوانا اسرائيليا بالصواريخ
على مواقع في حمص وريفها كما اعلن الحرس
الثوري الايراني مقتل اثنين من مستشاريه
العسكريين
بضواحي دمشق فجر الجمعه وتوعد بالرد ما
دوافع تصعيد الحكومه الاسرائيليه هجماتها
في سوريا كيف نقرا ردود فعل ايران على
استهداف اسرائيل مستشاريها في سوريا وما
هي المالات المحتمله بهذا التصعيد
الاسرائيلي في سوريا وكيف يمكن ان ينعكس
على استقرار المنطقه ومصالح دولها
على مستوى المحلي او على المستوى الداخلي
في دوله اسرائيل في عده رسائل اسرائيل
تريد ان ترسلها لايران نحن سمعنا وزير
الدفاع جالنت يتهم ايران وحزب الله بترتيب
العمليه التي نفذت في ميغيدو والتي حتى
الان اسرائيل لم ترد عليها وهذا يمس بقوه
الردع الاسرائيليه الهدف الثاني هو طبعا
ارسال رساله بان الامور الداخليه في دوله
اسرائيل
والخلافات حول قضيه الانقلاب ومحاوله
الانقلاب لا تؤثر على الجهه الامنيه
والهدف الاسرائيلي المعلن لاخراج ايران من
سوريا
والقضاء على اوراق القوه الايرانيه ومن
ضمنها هذا النفوذ الاقليمي لايران لكن هذا
التصعيد الاسرائيلي مرتبط باكثر من
الناحيه واحده منها ان ايران فعليا بدات
تخفف من تعداد قواتها في سوريا لانها
تعتقد بان التسويه السياسيه في طريقها الى
ان تصبح
واقعا وانها استطعت ان تبني نفوذا لم يعد
بحاجه الى وجود هذا هذا النوع من القوات
في سوريا المساله الثانيه ان القوات التي
يتم استهدافها اما انها عناصر لها علاقه
مباشره بمواجهه اسرائيل او عناصر فنيه من
الحرس الثوري متخصصه في الدفاعات الجويه
من جانب اخر اسرائيل تحاول ان ترسل رسائل
بان بانها ما زالت قادره على ان تفعل في
المنطقه بمعنى انها تريد ان تجذب اليها
القرار الامريكي بغيه التصعيد ضد ايران كل
الحراك الدبلوماسي الدائر في المنطقه لا
يمكن التقليل باي شكل من الاشكال تطور
العلاقات مع السعوديه
يعني احنا شايفين نقطتين ضعف بالنسبه
لايران النقطه الاولى هي التغلغل
الاستخباراتي القوي الاسرائيلي في قلب
ايران تقريبا في كل الاجهزه الايرانيه
ونحن نرى هذا في دقه
الاصابات القضيه الثانيه نيران لا تستطيع
عمليا نحن راينا مثلا نحاولت في اليونان
ان تنتقم من اسرائيل وفاشلت ايران لا تريد
تصعيدا في هذه الفتره لاكثر من من سبب
اولا هي تريد ان مسار اولويات الجوار ان
ياخذ بعده الناجح الى ابعد مدى بمعنى ان
تاخذ العلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه شكلا
فيه اكثر من مجرد التهدئه وعوده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بمعنى حل حالات بعض الملفات
الاشكاليه مثل اليمن سوريا وغيرها من
الملفات المساله الاخرى هي ايضا تحتاج الى
ان
تقوي من مساله ايج اد بدائل اقتصاديه
نتيجه
العقوبات والحصار ولذلك ايضا تحتاج الى
التهدئه
باعتقاد انه حكومه اسرائيل تدرك بان هناك
تحركات على مستوى كبير التقارب السعودي
وغالبيه الدول الخليج مع سوريا من التقارب
السوري المصري كل هذا يؤثر سلبا على على
اسرائيل وواضح بانه التقارب بين العرب
عاده هو ليس في صالح دوله اسرائيل نتنياهو
موجود في مازق طبعا نتنياهو يراوغ الان هو
اوقف حاليا الانقلاب
ويتحدث عن مناقشات في بيت رئيس الدوله
ولكن في نهايه المطاف هذه مراوغه حرب الظل
ستبقى مستمره بين ايران واسرائيل في ظني
انه ستاخذ هذه المواجهه بعدا اكثر تصعيديا
اذا وصلت الى ورقه حزب الله بمعنى انه اذا
حدث هذه المواجهه بين حزب الله واسرائيل
فهي ستاخذ بعد تصعيدي بمعنى اننا سنشهد
حربا وليس مواجهه في منطقه الظل